>>> WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
THE UNION."
I'M JAKEAPPER.
FEARS ABOUT A RECESSION EASED
THIS WEEK AFTEANOTHER STRONG
LIKELY TO RAISE INTEREST RATES
LATER THIS MONTH AND HIGH
INFLATION CONTINUING TO PUSH UP
THE COST OF EVERYTHING YOU BUY,
AMERICANS REMAIN DEEPLY UNEASY
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
JUST MONTHS BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
JOINING US NOW, NEW HAMPSHIRE
GOVERNOR CHRIS SUNUNU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE U.S. ECONOMY HAS NOW
RECOVERED ALL OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR JOBS LOST DURING THE
PANDEMIC, GAS PRICES AFTER
SHOOTING UP HAVE BEEN DROPPING
STEADILY FOR MORE THAN THREE
WEEKS.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS SIGNS THAT AN
ECONOMIC OUTLOOK -- THE ECONOMIC
OUTLOOK IS GOING TO IMPROVE,
BEGINNING TO IMPROVE, OR ARE YOU
WORRIED ABOUT A RECESSION
COMING?
>> RECESSION IS COMING.
YOU CANNOT ADD $5 TRILLION ONTO
AMERICA'S BALANCE SHEET AND JUST
HOPE IT GOES AWAY.
THE RECESSION IS COMING.
THE FED, I THINK, HAS KNOWN THIS
FOR A WHILE.
THEY'VE KIND OF IGNORED IT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN EASING US
INTO, YOU KNOW, THE RIGHT RATES
AND WHERE WE NEED TO GO OVER A
YEAR AGO.
YOU HAD A TREASURY SECRETARY
SAYING IT'S NOT INEVITABLE.
OF COURSE IT'S INEVITABLE.
YOU DON'T NEED FOUR YEARS OF
DARTMOUTH ECONOMICS THAT WHEN
YOU ADD $5 TRILLION THERE'S AN
UNFORTUNATE OUTCOME.
THE OUTCOME, HIGH GAS PRICES,
HIGH HOUSING PRICES, THE PRICE
OF A TACO IS GETTING UNBEARABLE
AND IT HITS LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES VERY, VERY HARD.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE ISSUE
GOING FORWARD.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO DO ABOUT
IT, IF ANYTHING?
WELL, THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS.
LOOK, I WOULD FIRE THE TREASURY
SECRETARY.
I THINK SHE'S COMPLETELY MISLED
AMERICA BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T WANT
TO KIND OF OWN THE BAD NEWS.
THAT'S PART OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
YOU HAVE TO OWN THE GOOD WITH
THE BAD.
YOU HAVE TO EASE FOLKS INTO IT
AND PROVIDE A GLADE PATH.
THE MORE THE ADMINISTRATION
TELLS AMERICANS THAT RECESSION
IS INEVITABLE.
HOME HEATING OIL PRICES ARE
STILL GOING TO BE AT RECORD
RATES THIS WINTER.
JUST HAVING PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES, ELDERLY COUPLE, FOLKS ON
FIXED INCOME, JUST TO HEAT THEIR
HOMES THIS WINTER, THAT FUEL
CRISIS THAT YET TO REAR ITS UGLY
HEAD BUT, BELIEVE YOU ME, THAT
IS TO COME.
WE HAVE HIGH ENERGY PRICES NOW.
COSTS TWICE AS MUCH TO FILL YOUR
GAS TANKS.
AND ALL OF THAT REALLY COMES TO
BEAR.
IT'S NOT GOING ANY AWAY ANY TIME
SOON.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT OTHER
INITIAL ISSUES.
YOU HAVE SAID ABORTION WILL
REMAIN LEGAL IN NEW HAMPSHIRE UP
TO 24 WEEKS, BUT SO FAR AT LEAST
NINE REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED
STATES HAVE NEAR TOTAL BANS IN
EFFECT WITH NO EXCEPTIONS FOR
RAPE OR INCEST.
SOME REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE
LOOKING TO GO EVEN FURTHER BY
LIMITING ACCESS TO CONTRACEPTION
AND RESTRICTING WOMEN'S ABILITY
TO CROSS STATE LINES IF THEY
WANT TO GET AN ABORTION.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERN THAT
MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
ARE OVERREACHING WITH THESE
POLICIES?
>> I CAN SPEAK HERE IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE, WE AREN'T CHANGING
ANYTHING.
THE ACCESS WOMEN HAD TO ABORTION
IS THE SAME.
WE ARE NOT CHANGING ANYTHING.
IT'S A STATE ISSUE NOW.
EVERY STATE IS GOING TO REALLY
TRY TO FIND THEIR PATH.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LITTLE WHILE FOR SOME OF THIS
STUFF TO -- FOR FOLKS TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE IT'S TRULY GOING TO
SETTLE.
FOR A LONG TIME STATES HAD THE
BACK DROP OF ROE V. WADE, THE
PROTECTION, OF NOT THE FULL
ABORTION BAN BUT SOME STATES
WILL HAVE TOUGH DISCUSSIONS
COMING FORWARD, WITHOUT A DOUBT.
>> WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE WHEN YOU
HEAR SOMEONE LIKE SOUTH DAKOTA
GOVERNOR KRISTI NOEM WHO SAID
HER STATE'S LAW WOULD MAKE NO
EXCEPTION FOR A YOUNG GIRL WHO
GOT PREGNANT AFTER BEING RAPED?
>> YEAH, LOOK, I DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT AT ALL.
I JUST DON'T.
GOVERNOR AND FOLKS OF SOUTH
DAKOTA HAVE TO RECONCILE THAT.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT AND
THAT'S DEFINITELY NOT THE RULE
OF LAW IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
WE'LL KEEP IT ACCESSIBLE,
AVAILABLE AND MAKE SURE FOLKS
HAVE THAT CHOICE.
>> LAST MONTH CONGRESS PASSED
THE FIRST NEW FEDERAL GUN
LEGISLATION IN DECADES, WHICH
INCLUDES INCENTIVES FOR STATES
TO IMPLEMENT RED FLAG LAWS.
TWO YEARS AGO YOU VETOED A RED
FLAG LAW IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
HAS YOUR POSITION CHANGED AT ALL
SINCE THEN?
>> NO.
LOOK, THE RED FLAG LAW THAT CAME
TO NEW HAMPSHIRE, THAT WAS
OPPOSED BY THE COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
THAT WOULD HAVE CREATED
LOOPHOLES FOR BOYFRIEND AND
WHATNOT AND PREVENTED WOMEN FROM
CARRYING A FIREARM TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST OTHER
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS.
I THINK WHAT YOU SAW IN
ILLINOIS, RED FLAG LAWS AREN'T
THE END ALL, BE ALL.
THERE ARE RED FLAG LAWS THERE
THAT FAILED.
THE FACT WE'RE GOING TO SIGN A
LAW AND CALL IT A DAY AND MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT DAY WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE,
THESE MASS SHOOTINGS, YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A MUCH MORE ENCOMPASSING
APPROACH.
IT'S ALL THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF MENTAL
HEALTH, FINDING CONNECTIVITY FOR
THESE KIDS.
JUST THOSE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHERE TO GO FOR EMERGENCY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE.
HERE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, EVERY
STUDENT WILL HAVE AN EMERGENCY
HOT LINE ON THE BACK OF THEIR
ID.
THE CONCEPT OF ONE TRUSTED
ADULT, SOCIAL, EMOTIONAL
LEARNING IN SCHOOLS.
WE FOUGHT BACK THE TEACHERS
UNION IN NEW HAMPSHIRE TO MAKE
SURE EVERY TEACHER HAS SUICIDE
PREVENTION TRAINING AND MENTAL
HEALTH TRAINING, TO MAKE SURE
WHOEVER IS INTERACTING WITH
THOSE KIDS, WHOEVER IS SEEING
THEM THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THE DAY.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS, THERE'S A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES WITH THESE
SHOOTERS.
DISCONNECT, MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, TRAUMA.
THOSE CAN BE IDENTIFIED WHEN THE
COMMUNITY COMES TOGETHER AS A
WHOLE.
SO, I GO BACK TO THIS IDEA,
WE'RE JUST GOING TO SIGN A LAW
HERE AND BAN ANOTHER GUN THERE.
THAT ALL SOUNDS GOOD POLITICALLY
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY IS HAS
TO BE A COMMUNITY EFFORT TO
REALLY TACKLE THE PROBLEM.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT JANUARY 6th
BECAUSE LAST YEAR YOU SAID
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S, QUOTE,
RHETORIC AND ACTIONS CONTRIBUTED
TO THE INSURRECTION AT THE
UNITED STATES CAPITOL BUILDING,
END QUOTE.
BECAUSE OF THE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS WE HEARD PRESIDENT
TRUMP KNEW THE CROWD WAS ARMED,
WANTED TO ESCORT THE MOB UP TO
THE CAPITOL, WANTED TO GO WITH
THEM, RESISTED TAKING ANY ACTION
WHILE CONGRESS WAS BEING
OVERRUN, DESPITE CALLS COMING
IN, PLEADING WITH HIM TO TAKE
ACTION.
WHAT'S BEEN YOUR REACTION TO
THESE HEARINGS?
>> LOOK, I'VE WATCHED A LITTLE
BIT OF THE TESTIMONY HERE AND
THERE, BITS AND PIECES.
SOME OF IT DEFINITELY CALLS A
LOT OF DECISION-MAKING INTO
QUESTION.
SOME OF IT YOU HAVE TO WONDER
WHERE IT'S COMING FROM.
IT'S SECOND AND THIRD-PARTY
HEARSAY TYPE STUFF.
DID IT REALLY HAPPEN?
DIDN'T IT REALLY HAPPEN?
I'M CURIOUS AS ANYONE WHERE IT
ALL FALLS OUT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THE POLITICAL
ISSUE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
ESPECIALLY WANT IT TO BE COME
NOVEMBER BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
DEFINE A PARTY.
DOESN'T DEFINE A PLAT FOR OR
POLICY.
MORE IF ANYTHING, IT DEFINES
SOME VERY BAD DECISION-MAKING,
PARTICULARLY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
ON A SINGLE DAY.
IT'S NOT JUST FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE CALLED TO THAT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
WANT TO FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
IT'S ALL ABOUT MAKING SURE IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT'S ALL ABOUT MAKING SURE YOU
PUT THE RIGHT PREVENTIVE
MEASURES IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
SITUATION AGAIN.
IT WAS JUST A TERRIBLE DAY.
>> THAT WAS A HORRIBLE DAY.
AS YOU KNOW, OF COURSE, TRUMP'S
ATTEMPT TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
WAS MANY MONTHS IN THE MAKING.
BUILT ON THE FOUNDATION OF LIES
ABOUT THE ELECTION.
AND A LOT OF REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES FOR GOVERNOR AROUND
THE COUNTRY ARE PUSHING THESE
LIES.
DOUG MAST ROEN ANY IN
PENNSYLVANIA, DARREN BAILEY,
ILLINOIS.
FULL-THROATED SUPPORTERS OF
THESE ELECTION LIES THAT HELPED
INCITE THE VIOLENCE AT THE
CAPITOL.
DO YOU SEE THAT AS
DISQUALIFYING?
>> WELL, IF I WERE -- IF I
WERE -- THEY WERE ON THE BALLOT
IN MY STATE, I WOULD DISQUALIFY
THEM.
YOU JUST PICKED THREE PRETTY
INTERESTING INDIVIDUALS.
THEY ALL DO HAPPEN TO BE RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR.
WE'LL SEE WHERE THOSE RACES END
UP.
LOOK, AS A VOTER, I THINK VOTERS
LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THEIR KITCHEN TABLE EVERY DAY.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S A DISQUALIFYING
ISSUE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE GAS PRICES,
INFLATION, HOUSING PRICES AND
THE LACK OF HOUSING AND ALL THIS
SORT OF THING.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE DRIVING FOLKS TO THE
POLLS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ONE
SINGLE DISQUALIFYING ISSUE.
MY SENSE IS IF THEY'RE PUSHING
THAT LIE, THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
AND OTHER PLATFORM POLICIES THAT
FOLKS MIGHT HAVE QUESTIONS WITH.
THAT'S SOMETHING EVERY VOTER HAS
TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES, LOOK
AT THE WHOLE PLATFORM, LOOK AT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN THEIR STATE
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR THEIR
FAMILY.
>> ASSUMING YOU ARE RE-ELECTED,
WILL YOU ENTERTAIN RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> GEE, IT'S -- IT'S SUNDAY
MORNING, JAKE, WE'RE GOING THERE
ALREADY?
>> I'M JUST WONDERING.
>> PEOPLE ASK ME THAT ALL THE
TIME.
NO, LOOK, I AM SO FOCUSED.
I LOVE NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I AM ADDICTED TO THIS STATE
ALMOST TO A FAULT.
I REALLY AM.
I LOVE BEING HERE.
I LOVE BEING GOVERNOR.
WE CAN REALLY MAKE CHANGES.
TOTALLY FOCUSED ON THIS
ELECTION.
GOT TO EARN EVERY VOTE.
THEN WE'LL TAKE NEXT YEAR, NEXT
YEAR.
REALLY FOCUSED ON WHAT HAPPENS
HERE.
I THINK WE'LL HAVE A POTENTIAL
SMALL COVID SURGE THIS WINTER.
WE NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR THAT.
I THINK INFLATION AND GAS PRICES
ARE VERY REAL, HITTING PEOPLE
HARD.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITY FOR
CUTTING PRICES BACK IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
THEN ALL THIS FEDERAL MONEY THAT
IS IN THESE STATES, HAVE YOU TO
SPEND IT WISELY.
YOU CAN'T CREATE MORE BIG
GOVERNMENT FOR IT.
ONE-TIME INVESTMENT IN SFRAUZ
AND THAT WILL GO ON FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS AND THAT'S WHERE MY
FOCUS